so if you need money that's number one
easiest thing to do
[Music]
and so what i wanted to cover today was
i was calling cash flows oxygen how to
get some
um but this is actually part of a larger
discussion
um that i'm half targeting towards my
coaches um
and half y'all can just join in on what
i would be talking to them about
and so um one of the skills that a coach
has to have and if you are coaching
yourself you are the coach you're the
master of your own domain you're the
coach of your own business right
and you have to coach you better than
anyone else can right that's good to
have outside counsel that's what we have
coaching that's why i get coaching
but you have to be your own coach
because you're the one who's going to be
making the decisions for your business
more than anyone else
right and so oftentimes
when i am on the phone with a business
owner i am listening
for the majority of the time of that
call and i'm looking for
certain things and so some of you may
have heard of
a swot analysis right strength
weaknesses opportunities and threats
more commonly now in mba schools they've
actually reversed that and they call it
an atsu and what that means is
opportunities threats are
disproportionately weighted as far more
important
and then then you have strengths
and weaknesses and so the reason that
i'm saying this is that
most times when i'm listening to a
client who's saying i'm struggling i'm
having an issue where i'm at a
bottleneck it doesn't necessarily need
to be
that they're losing money but just like
i can't get past this point what's the
issue
i'm going to be looking for cash flow
opportunities that are sitting on the
ground
and massive threats those are the two
things i'm looking for in the beginning
once those boxes check off then we go
down to strengths and weaknesses
for example if someone is bleeding cash
i'm not going to tell them to to to fix
their culture
right fixing their culture is something
that they absolutely need to do
but it's not going to be the thing
that's going to save their business
tomorrow right they need
money and so like it's one of the things
that drives me nuts because it's not
prioritizing the actions according to
the
to how important they are right and so
an example of this i mean i just use the
culture example but let me look at
another one here's a more relevant one
retention right and believe me i'm like
the king of making sure that you're
doing a good job to your customers right
but if your retention is [ __ ] right it's
absolute [ __ ]
um that's if you need to make payroll in
the next 30 days
implementing retention system is not
going to solve your problem it's going
to take 12 weeks for that's it for that
to pan out
now this is something you should do
absolutely
after you have milked out all the big
opportunities that sit in front of you
and ensure that you're not going to kill
yourself from a threat standpoint now
if you're if your retention is like you
know you're churning thirty percent of a
month and that becomes a threat it's not
even a weakness it's a threat itself to
your business
now the number one thing that i see
and this is like when i'm when i'm
getting on the phone now and like i i
occasionally take calls which i want to
kind of like just poke and listen
um and i tried to advertise it because i
i couldn't like i actually thought about
this like yesterday i was like i wonder
if i could take one call with everyone
if i did 30 minutes for every person
once a month and i was like oh no it's
still taking me three months
so i can't do it i tried and i thought
about it it can't work so all i do is
give you the lessons that i have learned
from the people that have spoken with
and so if for example you don't have a
one-on-one nutrition accountability
program that you have plugged into your
facility on top of your group training
that is the biggest opportunity that
sits on top of your business right now
would you like to have an extra fifteen
thousand dollars a month spent zero
dollars in ad spend
get it in 28 days and you have literally
no risk and it's only profit that you'd
add on top of your business
basically no cost you don't have that
cool nothing else that you are going to
do is going to matter
and so this is called opportunity cost
of all of the things that we can do
doing this alternative what other things
are we doing that we're saying no to
right picking out
which of the opportunities to focus on
is usually the
focus of a good coach and this is where
experience of a coach matters
because they have more plays in their
arsenal they have more
cards up their sleeve that they have
seen be executed
uh with precision over a short period of
time and so to a new coach
they may only have okay we need to run
more ads we need to work our leads
harder we need to sell better
those are all very true things those in
my opinion would sit within the
strengths and weaknesses area
right but if you are bleeding cash and
you need to make money fast
right there are three things that will
make you money fast
one is if like all three of them by the
way
include selling [ __ ] to your existing
customers that is it
you don't have enough time to start a
campaign bring people in market stuff
like that takes time
and if you don't have it then there's
only three ways to make money and all
three
are selling to your existing customer
base all right in a gym
the first and easiest and least amount
of anything
effort is to take three people run a
reason why
campaign which is like a uh hey i just
turned 30
and because of 30 i'm gonna take three
people with me on a one year
transformation it's gonna be awesome
and i'm only like i said i'm only taking
three people on it's me three thousand
dollars
you know text me if you want it just
like that you make nine grand
all right you have 100 people you're
gonna have to retake the offer all right
so if you need money
that's number one easiest thing to do
you don't want to sell
all of those limit it limit yourself but
those
cash pops help right cash is oxygen so
you can buy yourself time
to have more perspective to make better
judgments about the business
next play is you run an internal play to
your existing customers
right now i guess this one would
technically be like subset and subset b
which would be the final two
if you have like in a normal gym
if you just want to run like a big booty
boot camp or an abs challenge or uh
whatever right doesn't really matter
right buns and guts
any of those things you can market to
your existing customer base
and you have two things that you can do
from there one is you can actually sell
the thing itself
which normally you'll get about 20 25
take rate of your entire customer base
if you sell between 100 and 200
right and so if you have 150 people 25
would be whatever that is i don't know
uh
like 35-ish 40ish whatever somewhere in
there right
and so you have 35 people who sign up at
let's say 150.
okay well made five grand but then you
have some more fulfillment so
maybe the painful thing that the three
people might be a better player for that
so we'll see which one if you did the
other one recently then that that would
probably be the play dead
now if you wanted to make even more
money right then
you should make the thing free that
you're giving away
and then upsell them into food and
supplements right up sell them
additional services once they start
because you'll get an 85
take rate and you'll close 80 90 on the
upsell
right so it's more work but it again in
a short period of time
you can sell people other stuff that's
ancillary services
and that's all free money there's no
there's no fulfillment that really has
to happen there
right so like you buy something or in
our case
you don't buy something you just go into
prestige labs and you click send and
then they
you never have to touch inventory but
point is is like
you're taking something for five dollars
you're selling it for twenty and then
you just take the in-between
and that's it the exchange happens you
keep the money great
right so that's another easy way of
making 10
15 20 000 in a month the third thing
and this is the one that i'm going to
drill home for everyone is that you have
the same amount of effort
that is going to go into dealing with
any kind of internal play
so beyond the first thing which is like
quick text blasts limited spaces
make 10 grand tomorrow right that's like
cool make 10 grand tomorrow
but if you want to make like if you want
to start having established recurring
revenue
right add an additional level of service
right
simply giving people one-on-one
nutrition one-on-one accountability
that's it a lot of people struggle with
getting the gym a lot of people would
love someone
to text them every morning ask them what
their weight is how they're doing
make sure they show up at the gym what
this also does is your churn
goes through the floor as in like your
retention goes up
people stop turning up because they have
a regular communication hiddens now
if i had 150 customers what would i do
i would being the enterprising mofo that
i am
give everyone at my gym 28 days free or
21 days
or 14 days free depending on how much
work ethic i have right
now for me if i gave everyone in my gym
all 150 people
an amazing 101 experience that they've
never had before
and after those 28 days you can keep
doing this for 49 bucks extra a week
right and that's half of what i'm to
sell new people into it so they're
getting a great deal
right what percentage of people do you
think would say
you have 101 contact with them for a
whole month what do you think
half being a third would stay probably
higher than a third
i think half would stay i think it's
higher than a half but let's just say
half
right half stay now you're not going to
get 100 take rate because you never get
100 take rate
on these types of things but you get 85
let's say you get 120 people to take the
offer
or you can have to stay so you got 60
and you got 60 at 200 a month extra
that are paying for one one nutrition
accountability what's the cost of
fulfillment there
very low right 20 goes to a coach cool
so you pay 2 400 out of your out of your
12
right so you're at 96 and now
every single month from this month going
forward
you make your 10 grand a month and that
is profit that is
in your pocket that you can do tomorrow
right
so if you're if you need more profit if
you need more cash
there's a million ways to do it and a
lot of times like and this is me
somebody who's a long-term player
sometimes if you need it fast fixing
your culture is not going to do it
you need cash today and so once you can
have that and you can plug the hole or
you can plug a threat or whatever it is
right then you can start fixing the
processes that got you into this pickle
to begin with
but sometimes you need cash tomorrow and
so those are the three
easiest ways that you can get cash
tomorrow the last one one-on-one
nutrition accountability by
different um because of marketing so
don't get scared away nutrition
accountability is kind of part of the
game when you're a gym owner
um that being said it's free money
and so if i'm talking to a gym owner i'm
going to check off the boxes of which of
these things they have done
and most times when i look at all the
opportunities they have
floor in front of them asking them to
take it
and so right now if you're looking at
your business there's probably a million
things that you could do
and arguably should do but which one
thing
given the same amount of time is going
to make you the most money
forget about everything else and just do
that and most times you're gonna make
the right call
and what a good coach is supposed to do
is figure out of all the plays that they
know in their arsenal right all the
cards that they have to play
which one is best suited to you right
now that can have high impact
and and require low resources right
those are the best
high impact high resources like yes
it's going to take a lot but it's going
to it's going to cost a lot right
whereas here you actually get the
benefit of having the profit without the
risk right
i'm not saying front ad spend i'm not
saying you know like there's literally
nothing that
needs to get added to your business
besides one person with 60 clients one
person can handle that
and that can be you if you want to you
can keep the extra 2400 a month it's
your call
but all that to say if you're looking at
your business
it is your job to be able to weigh which
of the things that are in front of you
because there's a million plays that are
out there and that's where people get
overwhelmed they're like i don't know
should i run a 28-day transformation
should i run an internal play
should i run a a paid in full should i
run a year of change should i
run a like should i run hybrid
one-on-one accountability nutrition
right what should i do look at which one
makes you the most money it takes the
least amount of resources
depends how quickly you need the money
the money tomorrow you got to do paid in
full it's gonna be a text blast you make
the money
if you can if you can wait two weeks to
make the money you're gonna do an
internal play
if you can wait a month to make the
money then you should probably do hybrid
give everyone the free play and now you
just added 120 grand a month to your
facility
top line right and then bottom line you
add actually sorry
you would add more than that top line
you had 144 000 top line 120 bottom line
all right one play is it worth it
arguably
what most people do not that and that's
why they struggle
so don't be one of them cash flows
oxygen make sure that you
prioritize the opportunities that are
bigger and once you do that
once you execute those things then yes
you'll have cash flow to breathe
and then you can invest in things that
will actually solve your problem
then you can pay someone to start
helping retain your customers so that
you don't have the term problem and you
can wait 12 weeks and now you have cash
flow
from the recurring revenue stream that
you took a month to build
all right so i hope that makes sense
drop a like drop a comment tag someone
if you feel like it
three ways to make cash in the next
month lots of love keeping amazing
have a wacky wonderful wednesday all
right be cool
bye
[Music]
you